hi my name's Kira chambers and I'm Cody
Melchior and it's camera just suck and
Cody also just saw two as well
wonderfully camera was like I'm going to
dress up as Wonder Woman and I was like
okay well I have like a full like core
like we went in core Green Lantern
costume and then she was like well now
I'm going to go like kind of like casual
and I was like okay well I don't really
have the ability to do that how people
had Green Lantern yeah well just like
when I go at half-mast like still a fan
of the Opera I'm a big dogs got an OG
back in this day was the sign that will
actually have my own Scott costume I
went to him when I was young very I
shouldn't you a pic you're gonna put it
up I'd you just leave it I just I mean
what the hell guys I had the best time
ever watched this film it was about the
Wonder and a woman true that everything
was brought together nicely for what
they're trying to do in the DC Universe
with a serving of Justice League and
they're just kind of rushing it together
but like felt like they just it really
well here wasn't like this plaque be of
the faces that no one showed up thank
you you never know like see like this
suave assemble no so thing before yeah
they were gonna bring people in and it
was gonna be like all right let her have
her time
yeah they had like a minor Batman going
on and that was fine girl rocked it
she was so good yeah and Elsa dome gal
gadot gal gadot yeah gal gadot which
also tracked like a Pokemon thank god
she's so cool she was awesome
I'm gonna do it this film was something
that I wanted to do and I was like I
know I'm gonna love it even if it's not
good I'm still gonna love it it's like I
there's a few films like that when I
shower we're still only going on like
I'm gonna well it doesn't matter and to
be fair the ending of this movie was
Authority oh are you kidding for you
yeah it was a choose between them aha
together we can roll you so we're still
it was returned to the Jets away yeah I
loved it but it was definitely return to
the Jedi true that is not part of the
problem that the movies been having is
like people are channeling hold it up
just like standard because the requiring
Wonder Woman didn't need to be something
it's like look compared to the rest of
the films in the DC Universe compared to
the rest of the films across the board
in comic book movies in general and not
such as movie this year so that's
another it's doing great and like
there's many articles coming out now
where it's like you know like oh like
can can like a woman director who hasn't
really done much before this handle this
movie it's like look at all the like
male directors that are assigned you
know a movie suddenly from an indie film
and they're given a huge franchise a
Jurassic Park so many things are put on
the backs of specific movies and that is
just wonder when that happens all the
time with movie especially conflict
movies we want them to be these greater
things that are more than mean something
more and like this movie was great
it hasn't succeeded in the way to
succeed it and it falter sure look like
so just like Wonder Woman in the movie
it's pushed through and ultimately it
prevailed
except for one glaring problem and that
is that Wonder Woman speak 200 languages
and they're island Allen as the mascara
has been basically obscured from the
rest of the world since like ancient
Greece three times right and wait she
faked 100 languages
apparently that includes languages that
have been developed since Asian groups
like secondly terms like modern German
French and English which is like those
languages work very different when she
would have been also a different time
and I'm just saying it was a great movie
I loved the movie please don't get mad
at me but we do have to understand that
that's not how linguistics work and
upset me a one-column 3 of Y follows
look at me
I'm interested of course this is not
Hellenistic what I think that is a
beautiful critique oh even reference
where she's speaking ancient there was
one moment what is she saying
Oh we'll see about that looks like okay
that's a little model girl you kill your
friend
what was she said what's up for a good
time right but I'll just decide there's
a serious problem with the movie show is
a fantastic movie
oh yeah I wholeheartedly enjoy it at a
lot of fun I still do have a problem
with like shoehorning in romances I will
say for this movie because I mean maybe
then all superhero movies right I will
say in this one it at least kind of
played into the greater concept of the
film as well as the ending like it
wasn't just signed boy like it was an
actual like it was an actual plot device
I would give him that but I still that
was the lowest part of the movie with
that one really romantic scene was the
part where I could Carla have room yeah
I don't three eyes you were saying
that's fine I just you you're saying
we're allowed to disagree I know I like
that that's what makes us the Justice
League just wonder what was it like a
circus the reason why I take that their
love story was written so well did I
feel like media hate this but it's
because the other person like the side
person that wasn't Wonder Woman was a
man and usually when there's romances
that are shoehorned in it's this male
lead that the interesting male lead and
then they don't write the female and
interesting characters and they brokers
time is an interesting character with us
equally inches there was a great moment
of them being together and then at the
end they're out together and it's
beautifully done I think they did it in
a way that's like not hit me over the
head with it
I won't hate I will agree you kind of
win me over a little bit I hadn't really
thought about that way
yes I will agree I think I just have an
instant repulsion salmon romance she
weren't in the movies that don't need
one it's an action-adventure movie that
is my personal cross to bear
similar to poses Wonder Woman struck
several times and I just imagined Doug
Walker Rob Walker and Peter watch it I'm
just calling it out immediately it was
their favorite thing their favorite
night was a crane kick my fly policy
action was which I think it's just
generally how things are going
especially with Zack Snyder's in charge
of the universe up until recently is the
action started edging towards
transformers like there was some time
like I was like I was so hopeful that
she would have moments where she would
just like go full Wonder Woman and she
finally did about halfway through the
movie and that one was fine with in the
final product where it was just like so
much so many camera shifts and so much
happening y'all couldn't really follow
the actual fighting action and it's like
you didn't get that back ah I should
save it it's a little weird to critique
her body
everybody's amazing I do think it's kind
of a little weird that Wonder Woman
wasn't like that like built up a little
bit like at all
she's just like a really thin girl she's
badass is beautiful but right um it's
not this whole shake her body at all no
it's more like cast it'll equal anything
she also acted this out ritual is
so good but right but not something
they're fighting her whole life and like
just like a little like any know
anything so like that's just a little
weird something like oh yeah Chris Pratt
I mean like worked out hardcore to get
in shape least our Lord because
similarly star-lords a dude would be in
shape like he has to be and also they
wanted to be as example kind of for that
movie but so trouble is because he has
not really hurt the production thing I
like that the movie and she both did a
really good job of writing a line
between 90s and
actual yeah there was the the didn't
ieave access of her but she still did
make a week yes
thank god you're here to do that
I hope the characters were so well
written I thought even the side
characters who it was less of like a
like a group fighting together they were
just the side characters but I thought
that they were cheerful interesting yeah
she sure done how they were so
interesting I thought everyone from her
world was so interesting I just want to
live there like damn I love some blinds
I love the they don't deserve you line
crisp I was like we don't do that like
we we have to take the men who will do
it do you think I am the men who will do
it like yes girl
you are that that was so good that it
was so built up to everyone so scared to
see it that DC is just like one or the
other just put out crap and this was the
one that did well is just like get out
yeah I mean if it's definitely the
Smurfs philosophy of DC movie I mean
yeah that's really what everyone's been
saying let me this baby be like a
sorrows like the Gulf to recite nephews
I think okay I think next week might be
the mummy um oh it Kristen Captain
Underpants I think I might see that this
weekend I think it really go read watch
Wonder Woman this weekend okay my own
both their own super girls let's dress
up for it Oh goodbye everybody
Oh
[Music]